again Hardy in the upper ranks of the
Iranian military at the official
announcement of the death of
major-general Qasem Soleimani the
commander of Iran's cludes force the
Revolutionary Guard unit responsible for
foreign operations
sulemani was killed in a US drone strike
in Baghdad
and anger at Friday prayers in the
Iranian capital for the assassination of
a man who led the charge against ISIL in
Iraq and Syria and whose death seems
likely to lead to more conflict that's
too shaky God willing it is now time to
clear and cleanse the region of these
Devils it is now time to show more
resistance to the Americans and show our
assistance with action to tell those
Yankees to get out of here get lost in
the early hours of Friday morning
shortly after arriving at Baghdad
International Airport us missiles killed
sulemani and his close ally Abu Maffeo
Mohandas the deputy head of the Iranian
backed Iraqi militia hashed out shabby
other members of the group were also
killed in the attack a drone strike hit
their convoy as they left the airport
for Iran's supreme leader Ayatollah Ali
Khamenei sulemani was a trusted
confidant a member of his inner circle
his killing in a targeted attack the
most extreme escalation in tensions
between Tehran and Washington in recent
years Khamenei warned there will be
revenge
the cruelest people on earth
assassinated the Honorable commander who
courageously fought for years against
the evils and bandits of the world
so like manis martyrdom will make Iran
more decisive to resist America's
expansionism and to defend our Islamic
values with no doubt Iran and other
freedom seeking countries in the region
will take his revenge in Tehran senior
leaders met in an emergency meeting of
Iran's National Security Council many
Iranians see the u.s. attack as an act
of war across the region there will be
implications anywhere where there's an
American military presence Americans
should should leave those countries
immediately but if I was in the Emirates
I would leave now if I was an American
in Iraq
I would leave now if I was an American
any part in Southwest Asia
I would leave immediately the United
Nations High Commissioner for Human
Rights described the killings as a
likely violation of international law
the idea that Iran is not going to
respond is is wishful thinking that will
make the the debacle of invading Iraq
look like a walk in the park I do not
think the President Trump really
understands what he's got in the United
States into going up against Iran I
would argue that going to war with Iran
will be the most significant adversary
that the United States has encountered
since World War two US Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo tweeted a video
showing Iraqis celebrating the attack
while Soleimani enjoyed widespread
support for leading the charge to
displace ISIL from Iraqi strongholds
some Iraqis blame Iran for instability
and interference in their country and
sulemani directly for the deaths of more
than 500 Iraqis in violent
anti-government protests which began in
October feared by his enemies inside
Iran sulemani has for years been one of
the most popular national figures in the
country the international face of
Iranian resistance to American pressure
he remained largely untouched by the
waning popularity in recent years of the
country's government over economic
issues while there is talk of revenge
many Iranians don't want to see a war
well try enough we should not try to be
sharp on a rally mr. Trump unfortunately
acted decisively saying that we won't go
for war but pushed the issue to war the
leaders must exercise restraint so that
the tension of the region wouldn't
increase further because this can have
very serious consequences for the
countries in the region it will
definitely increase violence but I
fundamentally disagree with violence in
conflict I believe people moving toward
peace and negotiation to reach their
goals is much better
[Music]
irani ins looked on sulemani as someone
who could protect them cut down at the
height of his popularity by a US strike
his death marks the lowest point in Iran
US relations in decades
Zane Basra v al-jazeera